hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about some more a timi
waza so this is the last little part I
was talking to you guys about uh in the
receiving a timi waza and how not to do
that silly thing and how distance is
important and how to actually correctly
follow the context as as I outline it in
my Approach anyway so if you're
interested in how I talk about that this
video is for you I'm going to call Josh
over here we're going to go to work
Josh all right so so let's talk about
receiving a Tim waza and this is the
last one in the receiving series on a
Timmy waza that I'm going to talk about
so I think a really important thing to
remember and that we always forget is
that we should be keeping a distance of
our on step ma ey or greater when we're
dealing with someone who has a weapon
right so so in the last series we talked
that the reason we have the atimi waza
we have in iido is because there's a
weapon at play right and then we talked
about how our basic ideas about that is
to get my hand up and then if my timing
is such I make some kind of blend with
it that's that works really well for me
right okay now understand that I
shouldn't be waiting for him to get to
the the distance that he wants to attack
me because it's likely that if he gets
to that distance he's going to cut me
before I can do anything right so I'm
putting myself behind by always doing
that so what I'm trying to do is
increase the distance to at least this
distance or greater so that way I
dictate when he strikes right now I can
only dictate it so much because he
always has to choose when to strike so
there's going to be certain times when
I'm looking for him to strike right
whether he gets me in a corner or
whether um he thinks he's running up on
me whatever it is and those are the
moments I'm looking for and that's when
I have to make my blend so lots and lots
of training from this one step distance
is important because ideally if you're
working it right they won't get inside
of that one-step distance once they get
inside that one step distance he has all
the advantage right but at the one step
distance I have enough time to actually
blend successfully with him okay now
this is where we get away from the I'm
coming bro with the the the knife way up
in the air right okay what should be
happening is Josh should just be
normally tracking me around right we
only got so much room but he should just
be normally trying to track me like this
okay now notice he doesn't have to hold
the knife up in the air he doesn't have
to run he doesn't have to Signal
anything my job is to keep him at the
distance where it's difficult for him to
attack me and he'll have to Lunge in to
get me right so that's what dick Ates
that now a lot of times as UK we run in
like this because we wanted to know
we're coming with a yokan and a showman
right so we're being nice that you
shouldn't do that he should just keep
his hands down and I should be trying to
make that distance constantly and then
all of a sudden when he thinks he can
strike he will lunge and that's when I
need to be able to make good blends with
him right so my good blend comes because
there was an opportunity for him inside
of that distance to make it work so
that's how we get rid of the big I'm
coming for you bro thing and that's how
we should always be setting up our Gaza
don't think that I am trying to get the
knife from him what I'm always trying to
do is just keep distance if I could
spend all my geaz a time just keeping
distance from him then that's what I
would do and that's different than the
drills right so remember the drills we
had all the flowing drills right I want
to practice him coming in and then
switching over and then me having to
deal with that attack and then him
switching over and me having to deal
with that attack and so forth and so on
right so those drills train us how to
adapt to the Blends but in our Geo Wasa
time we should be trying to keep a great
distance that's what we're learning is
to keep distance and he'll be practicing
trying to work us into the corners and
as he works us into the corners he's
going to find times it's good for him to
attack now I should be highly aware that
time and be ready to blend with it right
so that's the basic progression there's
no big secret there other than to to
conceptually understand what's going on
I don't want to get in close to a guy
with a knife because that's where he has
his Advantage I want to make him
disadvantaged by having to Lunge out far
to get me and in that lunging out far is
all of our classic iido Blends so all
those blends you learned are used only
at that distance if he closes in on that
distance those Blends are not going to
become good for him so really what you
should be practicing is how to keep the
distance ideal for you that's good
Aikido so that I know that wasn't a big
super secret mystery but that's
basically how it works and we avoid the
I'm coming for you bro or holding the
thing right he should just be walking
around normally trying to track me down
and then when the opportunity arises
that I should be able to see before he
sees then to be able to blend with his
lunging in attack so I'm Christopher
behind this is Joshua th and Maya Salon
McDaniel is behind that camera right
over there that's acting weird so we
might not even be seeing it because it's
acting weird but if you're seeing it
then it's working fine and everything's
great all right we'll see you in the
next video